Are the real surreal. No,
I'm the real survivor. No,
I'm the real Siraj.
Hello world.
It's Saroj and top research lab open AI
has recently caused quite a controversy
in the Ai Community.
Their new AI model dubbed
Gpt to is truly remarkable.
It's able to generate texts
that legit looks like a human,
wrote it after being given some prompt.
The controversial part though is that in
their blog they stated that they didn't
want to release the fully trained
version of it because they were concerned
about potential malicious
applications of this technology.
Within a few days of that blog post,
almost every single well known AI
researcher had something to say about it.
On Twitter,
the director of research at Nvidia
got into a flame war with their policy
director.
The creator of Karastan announced it
as unnecessarily hyping up research and
many articles have now been written
about it that make it seem like the
terminator is about to bust out of
our computer screens and kill us all.
Just use a picture of Jigglypuff instead.
She is the most dangerous
fighter in super smash brothers.
The big question here is,
should open AI have kept
their model closed or should
they have open sourced it?
I'll answer that at the end of this video,
but first I'll start by explaining its
potential applications, both good and bad,
how it works in technical detail
and how we can prevent misuse.
Open Ai has done some phenomenal
work for the Ai Community.
Their algorithm dubbed open AI five beat
some of the world's best dota players.
Recently they developed an algorithm
that learned how to achieve a really high
score in the notoriously hard game
Montezuma's revenge from a single human
demonstration.
They trained a robotic hand to manipulate
physical objects with unprecedented
dexterity. I wonder what else
that hand could do. Interestingly,
a lot of the techniques they
used had existed for many years,
but what they showed was
that with enough scale,
these techniques will start to
surpass all previous metrics.
Reaching a new state of the art.
Their newest model gpt to is no different.
It's a collection of existing ideas
repackaged at scale and by scale I mean
trained on a lot of data using a lot of
computing power as is generally the case
when it comes to deep learning research.
The authors used a neuro architecture
called the transformer configured it.
What a progressively larger
number of parameters.
Then trained it to predict the next
word in a sequence of text using a large
dataset consisting of 40 gigabytes
of text scraped from the web.
When given the task of writing
a response to the prompt,
recycling is good for the world.
No, you could not be more wrong.
The algorithm generated a
detailed coherent argument
as to why recycling is bad
for the environment.
One of the open AI employees printed
that response out and taped it above the
companies recycling bin to remind people
of the power of AI when given a prompt
for what seems like a believable news
story, it's able to generate the rest.
I've never seen such coherent
texts generated by an AI before.
It's more convincing than 21 savage, his
American accent, like all technology.
Humans can use it to empower other humans
or exploit other humans in terms of
empowerment.
This could help end writer's block giving
aspiring authors the ability to ideate
much faster, give it a possible scenario
and it'll generate what could happen,
accelerating the ability to write.
It could also allow for endless
entertainment options in gaming,
allowing for narratives, storylines and
dialogues that are completely unique.
Every time you play through a game,
grand theft,
auto and gpt to is able
to not only write prompts,
it's also able to translate texts
from one language to another.
Summarize long articles and
answer trivia questions.
That means we can use this as a coherent
chat bot to help companies scale their
customer support.
We could give it any book or article or
scientific paper we'd like and have it
summarize the key points for us,
gpt to will save us time,
improve our ability to write and help
create more fulfilling experiences in
entertainment and gaming when it
comes to exploitation. However,
this could be used to generate
misleading news articles.
It can also be used to impersonate
others online and in general.
This brings us even closer to completely
automating the production of abusive or
faked content to post on
social media at scale.
We can be sure it will be used
in all the ways I've listed.
Both good and bad propaganda is as old
as language itself and propagandists have
used every available technology to
scale the distribution of their message.
What's different now is that no longer
is this kind of power limited to entities
like governments with enough money to
buy the necessary people and machines
capable of spreading their message.
Now anyone anywhere can do it at scale
with a model like gpt to before we
discuss ways of preventing misuse.
Let's discuss how it actually works.
Starting with, of course, as always,
the data gpt to was trained on a huge
corpus of links that were scraped from the
Internet.
The researchers collected their training
data by using reddit as a filter.
They collected the most up
voted links from reddit.
About 8 million of them
then scraped their text,
creating a compact training Dataset
of about 40 gigabytes in size.
They called it web text and extracted
the source text directly from html.
Then they needed to decide how to encode
the text so that I was in a proper
format to perform machine learning on.
They chose a technique called
bite pair and coding or Bpe,
which is used to encode
the input sequence.
BPE was originally proposed as a data
compression algorithm back in the 90s when
Green Day made good music then adopted
to solve the open vocabulary issue in
machine translation.
Since it's easy to run into rare and
unknown words when translating to a new
language, since rare words can often
be decomposed into multiple sub words,
BPE finds the best word segmentation
by iteratively and greedily merging
frequent pairs of characters.
It starts by treating
individual characters as tokens.
Then iteratively mergers.
The most common token pairs
end times after tokenization,
these tokens need to be arranged into
matrices to be ready to fed into a model
as inputs. Num Py, the Python Matrix.
Math library helps do
this for the model itself.
They used what's called a transformer.
Deep minds Alpha Star,
which be a top starcraft two player
also used a version of a transformer.
The transformer architecture was created
by the Google brain team and it's
turning out to be one of the largest
contributions to AI replacing recurrent
networks as the goto model
for sequence learning,
gpt to stands for generative
pre-training transformer to,
it's an unsupervised language model
built on the ideas of open Ai's first
version compared to the
original transformer
architecture proposed by Google,
the transformer decoder model used
by open AI discards the encoder part,
so there's only a single input sentence.
Instead of two separate
source and target sentences.
The model applies multiple transformer
blocks over the embeddings of input
sequences.
Each of these blocks contains what's
called a multi-headed self attention layer
and a feed forward layer.
Each of these layers perform a different
series of matrix operations on the
input data. The final output produces
a distribution over target tokens.
After a softmax normalization,
which is known to output probabilities.
There aren't explicit labels here.
It's merely asked to predict the next
word in the sequence given the previous
words.
If anything,
the label is actually just whatever word
it's asked to predict label section.
For the loss function. It uses what's
called the negative log likelihood,
but without backward computation in the
context window of size k located before
the target word, the loss looks like
this. It's not task specific either.
It uses the pretrained language model
directly, so say in a labeled Dataset,
each input has end tokens and one label.
Why gpt first processes
the inputs sequence through
the pretrained transformer
decoder and the last layers output for
the last token is the hidden state.
Then with only one new
trainable weight matrix,
it can predict a distribution
over potential. Next words,
every time it tries to
predict the next word,
it compute an error using the difference
between the actual word and the
predicted word and uses
that to update its weights.
Using Goodall gradient descent linked to
how that works in the video description
and that's it. It had zero prior
understanding of language or how it works.
Kind of like Kanye during interviews.
The training data isn't
even task specific,
but after training on it
over the course of a week,
using several cloud TPU is that likely
costs several tens of thousands of
dollars. It was able to generate
realistic texts, summarize articles,
translate languages and answer questions,
so how do we prevent misuse
of this kind of technology?
A group of Cambridge researchers created
a role playing game that anyone can
access in the browser right now called
get bad news.com you play the role of an
anonymous person who slowly rises to
power using an army of automated bots
spreading fake news.
It takes 15 minutes to play and lets you
see what it's like to create and spread
fake news at scale.
After I played it,
I definitely felt like I had a much more
critical eye when it came to reading
texts that I saw online.
Educating ourselves on the potential
for this technology is one part of the
solution. Similar to how when people
learned about the potential for Photoshop,
they became less likely to be fooled
when staying Photoshop pictures.
The other part of the solution
is ironically AI. Yes.
Using AI to fight AI,
I found a tool called big box that uses
AI to classify whether a piece of text
is real or fake after having been
trained on a labeled Dataset. It's basic,
but a really cool demo you can download
and run it pretty fast. Using docker,
I gave it the generated gpt to
text and it classified it as fake,
which was pretty cool. Sometimes
you have to fight fire with fire.
Technology will solve
many of our problems,
but it will also give us new problems to
deal with. Now back to the big question,
was it ethical for open AI to have
kept it's fully trained model private?
Plenty of people right now have the
ability to easily recreate gpt to from
scratch.
The instructions are all there.
They released a paper blog post and
the code for a smaller version of it.
I'm certain that the team at open AI was
aware of this before they released it
all. What they did was brave.
They've taken the first
step of asking the question,
how difficult should we
make this technology to use
and help start an important
ongoing dialogue in the community?
If a model is trained on private data,
like patient records,
that model could easily be reversed,
engineered to reveal patient identities.
And even if a model is
trained on fully public data,
sometimes aggregated data in the of ml
models can become more sensitive than the
data as a whole.
For example,
an authoritarian regime could reverse
engineer a model train on Twitter profiles
to find the location of
potential dissidents. Thus,
it's important to use privacy preserving
tools in general while developing AI
models linked to how that works. We'll be
in the video description in the future.
Open Ai and other research labs,
if they feel their model could be misused,
should commit to open sourcing
a model by a certain date.
That way it gives the rest of the
community time to come up with counter
measures for the potential negative uses.
And as for the sensationalist journalists,
please stop using terminator
images for AI new stories.
These are mathematical tools that can
be used to empower people or exploit
people,
not conscious super intelligent beings.
They are matrix operations being
computed on silicon chips powered by
electricity does sum it all up in a
single sentence. Keep calm and learn AI.
And what do you think
about an AI as a decision?
Let me know in the comments section and
please subscribe for more programming
videos. For now. I've
got to recreate gpt too,
so thanks for watching.